the groundwork of innovation and
achievement is ideas the ability to
imagine something that does not yet
exist to create synergy between our
thoughts and the world unfortunately
though our ideas are not always good in
general it is more likely that the
majority of our ideas are buried
but if hypothetically let's say one in
10 ideas are good then the goal is to
come up with as many ideas as possible
all it takes is one good idea coupled
with proper execution to ignite an
explosion of innovation and achievement
in order to capture and execute the rare
good ideas swimming around inside your
head you must go through a process of
idea collection this involves collecting
every idea that floats to the surface of
your consciousness there is a sea of
thought flowing beneath your conscious
perception filled with the potential for
powerful life-changing ideas ideas float
to the surface when they are facilitated
and inspired by new experiences new
understandings and new perspectives
to capitalize on this you must grab
every idea that surfaces and bring it
into Shore by simply writing your ideas
down you capture them but if not written
down promptly after consciously
perceiving them they will sink back into
the subconscious and there is no
guarantee that they will resurface once
you begin to gather your ideas on the
shoreline the next and very important
step is evaluation after letting your
ideas dry off for a bit
you must evaluate the validity and
potential of them you should trust in
the potential of your ideas but also
thoroughly examine them with objectivity
and reason if your ideas make it pass
this process go one further and test
them out with carefully selected friends
family members and colleagues observe
their reactions and open yourself up to
their feedback work to subtract your
pride and ego from the equation in order
to absorb their feedback fully and
without resistance any stake of vanity
that you hold within your idea prevents
clear and rational consideration of its
true potential
once you have genuinely considered both
your own and other people's evaluations
and you know in your heart of hearts
that you have synthesized an idea of
great value
you will become synchronized with its
energy you will struggle to think of
anything other than the pursuit of its
realization at which point you must
execute the idea you must work to bring
it into reality using any infrastructure
you have or can assemble once you have
made this decision to pursue an idea
into fruition you must follow it through
without waiver for the greatest demise
of a good idea is indecision and
uncertainty employ the power of
definitive effort towards a good idea
and allow it to take its course if the
idea is in fact a good one it will in
time bring great abundance to that which
it is designed to serve
[Music]
thank you for watching if you found
enjoyment and value in this video please
give it a thumbs up share your thoughts
in the comments below and if you are not
already be sure to subscribe to our
Channel we are constantly coming out
with new videos to help you experience
life with clarity and Wonder